the gates are shut behind me now those
last few hundred have passed through to
see the queen lying in state uh we have
the very last people actually uh to
witness uh witness that to experience
your own little piece of history um
chrissy you first you were the very last
person weren't you yes what an honor
yeah it is an honour i am currently
serving with the royal air force so to
be able to do that on behalf of the
royal air force and a female um to an
amazing lady that will never be replaced
it was an honor
so you served with the royal air force
just give me a sense of what she meant
to you
she obviously i
swore my allegiance to her and um i just
feel very proud of being in the air
force and being one of her subjects uh
you know for her
can you put into words what it was like
for you walking into that hall
walking into the hall the first time
because i went through a quarter past
one this morning and then thought that i
needed to go through again so i've just
obviously come through last last four
then and it i i just felt very proud
that i was there
and i and just honored very honoured
that i was given the privilege to be
able to go through again and obviously
be the last person i didn't realize it
was going to be like this
so you went through twice as well
yeah um and how far have you traveled
and how long did you have to wait both
times so
i haven't chugged that far i lived uh
just outside high wickham um and i uh
started queuing up at quarters five
yesterday afternoon
um and got through so it's about 14
hours but 14 hours well
as the gates closed behind you though
just now
what was going through your mind that
that you have witnessed history or
it wasn't until i realized this was all
gonna happen at the end but yeah
yeah it's amazing
and um
it's the day of the funeral the queen's
funeral
will you stay to market yes i will
it will be a long day but well worth it
i'm never gonna do this again in my
lifetime so
yeah
thank you so much for your time you've
also got your someone that you met in
the queue as well didn't know each other
before sema
you were the last among the last two
then effectively
what was it like for you
it was incredible to be able to come and
to
be here and to just pay my respects i've
adored her since i was a little girl i
moved from the middle east to the u.s
and then to the united kingdom for the
past 25 years
my beautiful son ariane's been born here
so he's british
and i call this place home and she made
me feel like i was at home here and safe
always happy i always looked up to her
and
not being able to see her again on tv
it's hard it's hard she inspired many
young women and i was one of them now
old but
she'll always be in my heart forever
did you want to be one of the last was
that intentional um i left actually
because i needed to rest up a little bit
and i came back and um
i thought about it and i said it's it's
nice to come back at the end and try and
be there at the end because
i didn't want to say goodbye but
it was it was better doing it when it's
not so hectic and i wanted to be one of
the last yeah
and and both of you just finally
can you put into words it's almost
tangible isn't it that this moment in
history that you have experienced
yeah and i think the people that you've
met that's the moment it's a friendship
that'll last forever that's right we
shared this together and that's what
makes it special and i think we're going
to be friends forever
and the queen brought us together
and there were many amazing people here
yes everybody that yes organized this
everybody that was stood around
stewarding exactly those young people
that stood out there for hours and hours
if it wasn't for them we wouldn't have
been able to do exactly cheering
everyone on wanting photos
um we took group photos of them didn't
we and we took with them and there were
parents here with little children that
was amazing you know and they were so
excited to be here it was nice to have
that atmosphere and to feel the unity
thank you both very much for your time
united in grief i think is is the right
phrase to use um
thousands of them know i say community
thousands of people united in group um
all queuing up for hours and hours over
the last few days a pilgrimage if you
like to see the queen lying
in state not just to see something but
also to feel something an almost
tangible part of history for the final
goodbye for the queen